buongiorno a tutti e io sono giorgio e
voglio porre prima di iniziare delle
domande non so quanti di voi
tornando a casa stasera oggi potranno
accendere la luce schioccando le dita
cambiare canale fischiettando la propria
canzone preferita oppure non so avviare
il forno la lavatrice la lavastoviglie
qualsiasi elettrodomestico battendo i
piedi
ok se la risposta è nessuno oppure pochi
allora a quello che vi sto per dire vi
sarà utile se la risposta invece è
possiamo farlo tutti
qui non posso farci niente anzi me ne
dovrei andare ora la mia
la mia idea qual è la mia idea è quella
di portare la robotica
nello specifico la domotica altro
parolone ma che in realtà significa
sostanzialmente automatizzare quelle
piccole azioni quotidiane connesse alla
propria abitazione in casa di ognuno di
voi con degli oggetti di riciclo con
degli oggetti di uso comune con degli
oggetti che tutti possiamo appunto
appunto utilizzare quindi una domotica
che sia fatta non di sistemi
costosissimi e ovviamente alla portata
di poche persone mano domotica che sia
fatta di riciclo di tanta passione di
tecnologia ovviamente è di
ecosostenibilità la domotica del riciclo
una domotica che ci permetta di appunto
compiere tutte quelle azioni che vi ho
spiegato ovviamente quelle sono un po al
limite però un qualcosa che ci aiuti con
tutti i piccoli problemi quotidiani che
ognuno di noi vive come è molto semplice
o meglio è abbastanza semplice con
iniziamo subito un diodo led che cos'è
un diodo letto un giuda le da una
lampadina appunto led che sono riuscito
a riciclare da un radiocomando ora
ognuno di voi credo abbia guidato almeno
una volta
avete presente quelle macchinine
radiocomandate oppure agli aeroplani
gli elicotteri qualsiasi cosa ecco quei
telecomandi solitamente hanno un led per
segnalare uno status acceso spento on
off lo riciclato sono riuscito svitando
qualche vite a riciclarlo ed eccolo qui
è il primo protagonista del mio talk
ma veniamo subito al secondo
protagonista una webcam
anche qui oggetto di uso comune oggetto
che credo ognuno di voi abbia utilizzato
almeno una volta nella propria vita un
oggetto che è stato riciclato anch'esso
aveva un vecchio computer e le
possibilità erano due o smentire o
smaltirlo normalmente oppure e farci
qualcosa o riciclato gran parte dei suoi
componenti fra cui appunto questa webcam
che è qui oggi e soprattutto la cosa che
mi fa più ridere è il terzo protagonista
di oggi un sensore di temperatura un
sensore di temperatura che sono riuscito
a trovare qui quasi sono degli occhiali
da spia sono degli occhiali che la mia
generazione ha sempre sognato di
possedere quando aveva intorno ai 4 agli
8 anni insomma avete presente il periodo
dell'esplosione di james bond detective
almeno personalmente avevo una passione
per questo tipo di oggetti non
chiedetemi il perché
però in questi occhiali c'era un sensore
di temperatura
me lo sto domandando tutt'oggi e non ne
ho idea del perché ho avanzato qualche
ipotesi ma non credo sia molto
pertinente come lavorano insieme però
questi oggetti cosa cosa succede
sono controllati tutti da questa
schedina qui ora le dimensioni forse
dietro non si vede molto bene però le
dimensioni sono quelle più o meno di una
carta di credito oggetto che avete tutti
però un computer è un computer si chiama
raspberry pi e economico e costa
all'incirca 20 dollari sul web e riesce
a gestire tutti questi oggetti che vi ho
presentato come vi faccio subito qualche
esempio
ora vi chiedo di immaginare delle
situazioni quotidiane
vi chiedo di immaginare ad esempio voi
lunedì al lavoro
anzi alla fine della giornata lavorativa
poiché tornate a casa e dovete preparare
la cena
dovete darvi da fare anche lì dopo
magari una stressante giornata di lavoro
ovviamente non me lo auguro e dovete
preparare la cena quanto sarebbe bello
se poteste mettere non so una pasta un
panino un forno la mattina prima davanti
la mattina e poi poter accendere il
forno da un oggetto che avete tutti ne
sono certo uno smartphone quanto 20
minuti prima di tornare a casa
accendete il forno tornata è l'unica
cosa che dovete fare è mangiare qualche
esempio appunto ve lo faccio vedere ora
questione interfaccia web open source
quindi disponibile online che ci
permette di controllare il raspberry pie
che vi ho presentato prima e vi chiedo
di immaginare di un fare un po di
immaginazione di immaginare che il diodo
led che vi ho presentato sia in realtà
un qualsiasi elettrodomestico
anzi vi dirò di più un qualsiasi oggetto
comandabile tramite elettricità piastra
induzione asciugacapelli televisione
qualsiasi oggetto comandabile tramite
elettricità con questo computer che
prima di tutto non è mio e che
ovviamente in secondo luogo non è
collegato assolutamente al mio progetto
possa accendere e spegnere il led voi lo
vedete a schermo con quel pulsante che
si accende e si spegne se poteste
avvicinarvi purtroppo non è possibile
vedreste il led che lampeggia e questo
appunto e la gestione da remoto
ora io lo sto facendo qui davanti a voi
per portarvi una dimostrazione ma
immaginate di essere in qualsiasi parte
del globo voi potreste farlo
tranquillamente potete controllare casa
vostra e quindi non solo vedere cose
acceso cosa è spento aver spento la luce
sono uscito avrò non lo so ho lasciato
la caldaia accesa e riscaldamento acceso
e non solo controllare quindi così
acceso cosa è spento ma interagire
intervenire e quindi accendere spegnere
effettuare delle operazioni a vostra
volta
ma veniamo al al sensore di temperatura
che vi ho presentato prima anche qui vi
voglio presentare una azione quotidiana
un'azione che tutti fanno credo almeno
d'inverno il riscaldamento ora le
d'inverno nella nl giornate più fredde
la cosa che si fa quando si torna a casa
e accendere il riscaldamento
ci sono due tipi di riscaldamento il
riscaldamento condominiale quindi non
dipende da voi in questo caso mi
dispiace ma non potete farci molto il
riscaldamento invece casalingo quindi
voi avete un impianto tutto vostro
dipende dalla vostra caldaia e appunto
andate voi ad intervenire per accendere
e spegnere che cosa fate di solito è
bene o andate lì con la manina
manualmente accendete spegnete
l'impianto fantastico sì però un po
obsoleto per un nuovo inizio nel futuro
insomma non la vedo molto bene è poi
soprattutto dovreste aspettare che
l'acqua in trinci scolo oppure che altro
fate impostate una soglia di temperatura
sotto alla quale l'impianto entra in
funzione automaticamente anche questo
fantastico
oppure ancora impostato un orario quindi
un timer è oltre quel determinato orario
ancora l'impianto di riscaldamento
funziona però vi chiedo di immaginarmi
una cosa ad esempio la temperatura cala
sottomettiamo 18 gradi e me voi siete
del lavoro ok futuro siamo nel futuro
quindi quanto spreco di energie quanto
spreco di risorse anche economiche
no non va bene
impostate l'orario terza opzione anche
qui ok sapete che tornate a casa alle 8
ogni sera ci sto impostate l'orario alle
otto meno 10 si avvia l'impianto di
riscaldamento
trovate la casa già calda fantastico ma
sia un amico vi invita a non so a bere
qualcosa oppure se fate tardi perché il
capo vi ha chiesto di trattenervi e
anche qui quanto spreco di energia
quanto spreco di risorse anche
economiche
e se poteste controllare la temperatura
di casa vostra tramite il vostro
smartphone e allo stesso tempo
controllare l'impianto di riscaldamento
e decidere se accenderlo spegnerlo
faccio subito un esempio ok ok qui in
sala ci sono all'incirca 23.88 gradi
anzi all'incirca è una misurazione
abbastanza precisa è perché perché
l'impianto di riscaldamento qui è acceso
e come vi ho fatto vedere prima questa
misura
azione può essere abbinata alla
accensione e allo spegnimento appunto
dell'impianto come l'accensione e lo
spegnimento di questo led
oramai tutti i termostati sono solo
elettronici quindi possono essere
comandati tramite elettricità e quindi è
uno degli esempi che vi potevo fare
prima ma che non vi ho portato proprio
perché volevo descrivere velo un po
meglio ma veniamo al terzo elemento la
webcam
anche qui vecchia webcam
anche qui perdonatemi anche qui
riciclata anche qui una domotica
sostenibile se ciò va bè un'automatica
sostenibile e una domotica appunto fatta
di riciclo di tanta tanta passione
fantastico allora questi siete voi
questi siete voi un pò inclinati questi
siete voi la webcam si sta muovendo e
siete voi e io vi sto guardando
attraverso questa webcam che non è
collegata a questo computer quindi come
visto guardando io adesso sto
proiettando l'immagine su quello schermo
potrebbe farlo chiunque ovviamente
attraverso delle credenziali ci sono dei
protocolli di sicurezza da qualsiasi
parte del mondo
immaginate non so siete andati in
vacanza oltre di aver controllato se
avete spento le luci di casa
immaginate di voler controllare ad
esempio ok ma casa è al sicuro
cioè io non mi fido molto perché non
dare una controllatina accendo il mio
smartphone connessione ad internet e
controllo
fantastico immaginate ancora di più
immaginate che questa webcam rilevi un
movimento cosa che effettivamente fa e
li mandi un messaggio sul cellulare
voi direte si sono sistemi che esistono
e verissimo sono sistemi che per fortuna
esistono questi di videosorveglianza da
remoto
però sono sistemi che costano su sistemi
molto costosi che richiedono
installazioni particolari che richiedono
intervento di tecnici specializzati e in
realtà ci sono degli espedienti come
quello che vi ho portato io oggi che
possono invece semplificare il tutto sia
dal punto di vista economico che
ovviamente dal punto di vista delle
tempistiche appunto l'idea che vi porti
che vi che vi ho portato nel concreto
per un nuovo inizio è questa
però vi voglio dire una cosa io non sono
non solo lui
io non sono un genio io sono un ragazzo
normalissimo con una passione che è
quella della domotica quella della
robotica e che si è messo in gioco
infatti altrimenti non sarei qui e che
ha voluto appunto realizzare un qualcosa
proiettato nel futuro però sono un
ragazzo normalissimo con una passione
come come l'hanno tutti tutti noi
giovani abbiamo una passione abbiamo
tante energie e abbiamo tanta voglia di
fare l'unica cosa e canalizzare le
nostre energie
magari attraverso un apprendimento 2.0
un apprendimento tramite il web cosa che
ho fatto io magari attraverso non so
qualsiasi altra cosa un mentore una
persona che ci può ispirare qualsiasi
cosa però canalizzare le nostre energie
portare avanti i nostri progetti e
sicuramente crederci crederci crederci
crederci avere fiducia in noi avere
passione e avere anche ambizione avere
delle aspettative
e voi invece siete pronti ad entrare nel
futuro
grazie a tutti